بخطن يثقلها مرض الملاريا يصل محسن الى
هذا المركز العلاجي املا وضع حد لمرض
لازمه لاشهر فهو واحد من مليون و700 الف
سوداني هدد مرض الملاري حياتهم خلال
الاشهر السابقه يقول ان رحله علاجه للتخلص
منها مستمره منذ عام فما عاد في القدره
متسع لتحمل التبعات المرض الذي ضرب معظم
ولايات البلاد
اتمنى العلاج
كثيره لكن للاسف الشديد ما زالت النهاري
موجوده ومتكرره يعني
مستشفى المناطق الحاره الحكوميه بالخرطوم
هو خط المواجهه الاول لعلاج مرض الملاريا
يستقبل المستشفى نحو 60 مريضا في اليوم
ومع وصول الملاري عتبه الوباء فتنه عشر
ولايه بالسودان غدت المرافق الصحيه امام
تحديات مواجهه المرض
فمكانياتها الرهينه تلوح ضعيفه امام
معدلات عاليه يسجلها المرض
لاعاده تاهيل
لانه يمكن مين السبعينات ما حصل تغيير
كثير في الدنيا التحتيه بتاعه المستشفى
وبحسب التقرير لوزاره الصحه السودانيه فان
الاوضاع البيئيه التي خلفها موسم الخريف
الماضي فاقمت معدلات الاصابه بالملاريا في
عدد من الولايات كما ان الوزاره كشفت عن
اسباب اخرى وراء النسب المرتفعات
للمرضى
فيه شريحه كبيره من السودانيين معتمدين
عليهم
والاستراتيجيات بتاعه مكافحه الناقله
ينقطعت
هذه جزيره توتي بالخرطوم
تم استهدافها ضمن حمله شرعت في توزيع 18
مليون ناموسيه في عموم البلاد الحمله هي
الاكبر منذ سنوات ويتوقع ان تسم في زياده
استخدام الناموسيات بنسبه تصل ل 75% وتخفض
بدورها نسبه الوفيات والمصابين بمرض
الملاريا
بعد ان تفشل وباءوا في اثنتي عشره ولايه
سودانيه خلال الاشهر الماضيه يامل السودان
دعما عاجلا من منظمه الصحه العالميه يركز
على تعزيز نظام مراقبه وتتبع مرض
الميلاديه فقدرات الدوله ومؤسساتها الصحيه
تبدو قاصره حتى الان عن وقفه تمدده
وانتشاره هذا المرض نزار البداوي الجزيره
الخرطوم